supernatural sam and dean winchester
played by jared padalecki and jensen
ackles battled legions of monsters for
15 seasons alongside countless guest
stars
some left until their characters
returned to life some left because their
characters were misunderstood
and some left for other reasons find out
why they really said goodbye
mark shepherd played crowley the demonic
king of hell
in seasons 5 through 12 and he became an
integral part of the show
he secretly aided and openly antagonized
the winchester brothers acting as a
friend or foe whenever it was most
convenient for his purposes
but shepard felt that his character
deserved a better send off from the show
than the way his final exit was written
in which he sacrificed himself on an
angel's blade
in a fan q a he expressed his
disappointment saying
once they decided they needed to do
something different with the direction
of the show
they tried to get rid of me without
telling me that they were going to get
rid of me
i'd gone from being the smartest
character on the show to being the
dumbest character on the show in two
seasons they ran out of what to do
no one in the history of torch has been
tortured with torture
like the torture you'll be tortured with
needless to say
shepard did not part company with the
show on the best of terms dj quarles
joined supernatural in season seven as
demon hunter garfitzgerald
who preferred working alone but was
occasionally willing to team up with the
winchesters
he later underwent an intense
transformation when he became a
werewolf quarles was very appreciative
of the fan's enthusiastic support
and said he had loved working on
supernatural but there was simply no
room in his schedule to return to the
show
he told tv guide i'm so busy right now
i'm on a couple different shows and i
have two films lined up after this
he regretted having let the supernatural
fandom down and promised to make time
for the show
eventually returning for guest spots in
seasons 14 and 15.
katie cassidy was the first actress on
the show to play ruby
a demon who almost tore the winchester
brothers close relationship apart
cassidy said she felt that leaving
supernatural was heartbreaking
why did she exit despite loving her time
on the show so much
according to series creator eric kripke
the production company could no longer
afford to keep her on the payroll but
cassidy offered a slightly different
explanation
she told tv guide warner brothers wasn't
exactly sure what they were going to do
with my character
and i had the option to stay or leave
when harper's island came about i was
really into it so i asked them to let me
go
luckily they did when genevieve cortezi
joined the cast of supernatural in
season 4 to take over the role of the
demon ruby
she didn't expect that it would
completely change her life
but ruby's scandalous on-screen
relationship with sam winchester
blossomed into genevieve's real-life
romance with jared patalecki who
admitted that he waited about
four months before asking her on a date
his patience paid off in a big way
they were married not long after the
fourth season wreck
and she became genevieve padalecki
in 2012 genevieve gave birth to the
couple's first child
a son named thomas and then their
children austin and odette arrived soon
after in 2013 and 2017.
hadalecki has focused on family since
then largely retiring from acting but
did return
to supernatural for a guest spot in the
final season
jeffrey dean morgan was an original cast
member on supernatural
he played sam and dean's father john
winchester who became a demon hunter
after his wife sam and dean's mother was
killed by a demon
given how important he was in the
brothers lives having sent them down
their path
it's surprising he doesn't appear much
past season 3.
although the showrunners had wanted to
keep him on and feature him more after
season 2
morgan's busy schedule left them with no
choice writer's sarah gamble told
digital spy
we would love to have him back but he's
really busy he's turned into a huge star
over here
we got to use his voice for an episode
at the end of last season so there's
always a chance we would love to bring
back the character
if our schedules ever lined up but i
don't think anyone should hold their
breath
thankfully morgan was able to return for
several guest spots as jon in later
seasons of the show
alona tall became part of the
supernatural cast in season 2
as joe harvell whose mother ellen was a
friend of the winchester's dad
joe teamed up with him to hunt demons
until her death and appeared as a ghost
in season 7
then never returned again tall said that
she would have embraced the opportunity
to appear on supernatural again as joe
but she worried that the show's new
leadership didn't seem to fully
understand what she
and samantha ferris who had played her
mother had brought to the table
she told mea worldwide i think what
happened
was that when samantha and i were part
of the show there were different heads
of creative
but the people running things there have
changed and i don't think they know us
very well
or know our characters she also stated
that she hoped to appear in the series
final season
but it didn't pan out julian richings
played death himself
also known as the grim reaper or the
pale horseman on supernatural
his appearances were rare but
unforgettable especially considering
death's weakness for fattening food
he just couldn't resist eating a meal at
a diner richings made his final
appearance as death in season 10 and in
the following seasons
lisa berry took over the role by the
time his last episode had come around
richings had already taken on a new
recurring role
as the shadowy benjamin kirtland on
orphan black
and it was the perfect time to step away
richings always seemed to have a full
schedule
and since then he's landed roles on
series including 12 monkeys and doom
patrol
richard spade jr played the archangel
gabriel disguised as the trickster loki
though always mischievous gabriel
eventually sided with the winchesters
gabriel met his end in season 13 but as
it turned out
spate himself never really left
supernatural at all
in addition to acting spate left his
mark by directing several episodes of
the series including some in the final
season
he was behind the camera for proverbs 17
3
our father who aren't in heaven and
galaxy brain
kurt fuller appeared on supernatural as
the villainous angel
zechariah fuller embraced the chance to
play an unsaintly bad guy and ended up
really enjoying it in fact he felt a
little guilty about it
admitting to himself he needed a change
fuller jumped at the opportunity to join
the situation comedy better with you
which he described as a welcome relief
after his time on supernatural
he told staying in making people laugh
rather than making people bleed is much
more fun
and i feel better about it this is
definitely better for my soul
carrie anne fleming appeared on
supernatural as karen singer
wife of supporting character bobby
singer she had been possessed by a demon
and then killed by her husband bobby who
didn't understand the paranormal nature
of what had happened to her
fleming's first guest appearance on the
show was marred by personal troubles
as she struggled with postpartum
depression at the time
sadly she was also preparing to leave
her marriage
fleming would later joke to fans that
white clown makeup and no sleep was all
it took to make her look like a genuine
zombie but at the time
she was so deeply troubled she could
barely get through a day on set
she told times colonists i was having
trouble being happy
i had trouble memorizing dialogue and
communicating
she did return to supernatural in season
seven which was hopefully a better
experience
fans of supernatural know rick worthy as
the alpha vampire the very first member
of the vampire species but when worthy
first auditioned
he had wanted to play a much more
prominent and longer-term role
crowley he told digital spy i really
wanted to be on the show and i had
auditioned probably
five or six times before i auditioned
for the role of crowley which i thought
was a great role
and was devastated just devastated when
i didn't get it
unfortunately because worthy wasn't
chosen for a major role he couldn't stay
on supernatural as long as he'd really
wanted
he went on to other roles including the
strict dean fogg on the magicians
when we freaks die
where do we go not heaven
not hell so
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you